I got to do some porridge in a minute
you want some porridge yeah
like care in the community is in crisis
the shortage of care workers to support
people in their own homes has never been
this bad prisoner by default
it leaves unpaid relatives like Dorothy
at Breaking Point
I did
oh one day at a time says her husband
Melvin who has Ataxia a rare brain
condition which affects his balance
muscles and speech
oh
you know part of this being a carer it's
not just the physical and the challenge
and the Practical side it's what people
don't realize it's the emotional side
yeah
[Music]
you enjoy food
but you have difficulty moving around
my legs
remember
[Music]
my legs don't do what my mind tells them
to do my legs don't do what my mind
tells them Melvin says
the couple have been together for 48
years
Melvin who helped design the nose
prototype on Concord is now aged 76.
he is fragile and completely reliant on
his wife
yeah
but for two years Dorothy has struggled
to find carers for Melvin's complex
needs they're a rotation of different
ones coming in so I would end up just
showing them what to do because I
couldn't leave somebody to just say
right it's all yours so it's it's just
broken down that way what's the toll
that this is taking on you
people think from looking from the
outside in or they're managing you know
they're doing very well you know Dorothy
is doing that with Marvin every day she
makes it look easy because I do it so so
much but really I'm really crying inside
going
somebody help me behind closed doors and
Untold number of people are struggling
to care for loved ones
there are now more than 165
000 unfilled jobs in adult social care
there aren't enough carers to support
Britain's aging population
successive governments have pledged to
overhaul the sector we will fix the
crisis in Social care once and for all
with a clear plan we have prepared
but campaigners say it hasn't been
enough and this week's budget again
prioritized to the NHS
I have to say I'm sick of hearing about
the NHS and I'm sick of hearing about
politicians who seem to think it sits in
The Silo unconnected to every other bit
of the system not least of which how you
support people well in communities so
they don't go into crisis and don't need
the NHS but relatives say that's exactly
what happened to 97 year old Arthur
Brown who was sent home from hospital
with a catheter which neither they nor
he knew how to empty
is the pulling out of the catheter and
the infections and the the damage that
he's done pulling on the catheter that
has made him as bad as he is
his daughter-in-law Wendy says Arthur's
Family tried to care for him as best
they could she's 73. she says they
couldn't cope Wendy believes the lack of
a proper care package led to repeated
emergencies and three stays in hospital
now he said to me he's not really been
conscious and not really been able to
talk to anybody
um and I went in one day and the doctor
said to me that they were getting him
ready for discharge I said what do you
mean discharge where are you going to
discharge him to I said you can't
possibly send him home how do you think
he's going to cope I was so angry and I
my daughter had to come pick me up
because I couldn't drive the car
Arthur thought in the second world war
he's only just moved into a care home
the memory of what it was like trying to
look after him still weighs heavy
if it was something I didn't do
and he died how could I live with myself
Wendy's emotions will resonate with many
for people like Dorothy respite remains
elusive in the absence of a clear
government strategy on social care
last Autumn the government pledged what
it called a record-breaking seven and a
half billion pounds of funding for the
sector over the next two years but this
week's budget again prioritized the NHS
Lisa Holland Sky News